sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luno if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the late
highlander fan show the reason i'm
smiling from it right now is because
that's a new intro and i think that was
really cool you can let me know if you
like it um so today's gonna be really
interesting we're talking about bitcoin
mining um i think it's a pretty hot
topic given everything that's going on
in the world um but before we delve into
this this particular episode actually
all of these episodes um are powered by
icon plus capital so they're a vc firm
so definitely go check them out and it's
also sponsored by blockfy who offer
really great interest rates um
especially on stable coins so i use them
i love them so definitely go check that
out so like i said today we are talking
about bitcoin mining now i am joined
with somebody who um was kind of on the
front page of the daily mail and there
was a really clickbaity headline um so
we're going to find out how accurate
this is but this is the headline
jp barrick dropped out of college and
turned 1400
investment into 1.3 million dollars in a
month through bitcoin mining
jp is that true welcome to the show is
it true well i did drop out of college i
did start with a small amount of money i
used to run at like a robotics camp when
i was in high school
and used that money to buy
cryptocurrency in 2013 and beyond and i
did end up making over a million dollars
i wouldn't directly correlate it and i
didn't do it in a month but uh yes some
of those things are true the media loves
to take the story and make it you know
the headline even though you know they
take things out of context but at the
end of the day bitcoin mining has
brought me wealth
that's amazing yeah i mean it's always
taken out of context but i'm so excited
to go into this with you because we were
still talking backstage and i think that
right now mining is super hot just
because it is so affected by the
geopolitical landscape but before we do
delve into that can you just tell us you
know about your background what you do
um just so people know you know why
you're basically the expert to talk
about this
yeah so i got into the mining space in
2016 got into bitcoin in 2013 when i was
in high school uh went to college for
computer science dropped out of school
to start the company called mining store
and mining store has been focused on
bringing bitcoin and cryptocurrency
mining to retail and institutional
investors across the space and basically
making the mining space more accessible
um
and i
i was the original question i got into
this because of what
yeah no no no well the question was who
are you but that that's not true mining
store no well tell us what's mining
store just so people can finally yeah so
so mining store is a white glove
solutions to get into bitcoin mining
people who have no idea how to get into
mining or have really don't want to have
to deal with power bills don't have to
deal with hosting contracts don't have
to deal with replacement parts and
mining store provides all those services
and then in addition we're working with
influencers to launch their own mining
companies and make mining more
accessible by dropping the price of
getting into bitcoin mining from ten
thousand dollars or nine thousand
dollars to buy one miner to actually
like a hundred dollars now so we're
trying to make it super accessible and
available so anyone can invest in in a
mining operation
okay so we're going to talk about that
because i want to start mining because i
unfortunately don't so we're going to
get into that um but how did you then
hear about mining backdoors in 2017 like
how did you do that in college so in
2016 i was a senior in high school and i
was into crypto i had my own mining rig
in my parents basement you know just gpu
rigs i ended up buying some butterfly
labs miners that took forever to get
shipped they were like some of the first
asics built here in the united states
and then um i raised about a hundred
thousand dollars from family and friends
for my grandparents put up some money
myself uh from my own money yeah
especially as you know someone who was
17 years old maybe 18 years old
somewhere in that range so uh i took
that capital i bought 300 graphics cards
started mining in a old um kind of like
area where they made coats and made um
clothing and in graham north carolina
and then that's where the mining store
started was just a shopify store we
actually were selling the equipment we
were building custom rigs for people and
shipping it to them the problem is when
they arrived at the site of this other
individual that bought it on ebay they
were just so broken the mail just
destroyed them every time and so we kind
of learned like what we could and
couldn't do and how we could sell miners
online more effectively and from there
i've just been iterating on the process
to now where you know we're dropping the
barrier of entry and using new uh new
regulatory frameworks in order to in
order to do that
but how did you know what you're doing
because it's so early i mean even
raising a hundred thousand dollars is
wild
i mean for me i've always been an
entrepreneur so i mentioned the lego
robotics camp before uh my dad when i
was younger he was like if you want to
go to a summer camp you have to pay for
half of it and so let's go sell
strawberries to our neighbors and so we
walked around to the neighbors and said
hey do you want to buy strawberries i'm
going to go pick them and so my dad just
kind of
helped me grow and be an entrepreneur
and also gave me the
i guess the confidence to believe that
you can do whatever you put your mind to
and that you have the ability to you
know to grow a business and you have the
ability to make money and it's not
something that's only reserved for
people that are educated and in my you
know my sense i was only in high school
and since then i've learned a lot by a b
testing and then by running a company
just by doing it
i think that's such um an important
life lesson
um you know that it's just sort of what
your parents instill in you
um because so many people sort of have
this mindset that you have to come from
you know endless amounts of money
to be so called privileged but i really
think that having good parents that
instill um a really healthy work ethic
in you um and also just like not just
work ethic but like mentality within you
is the most privileged thing you could
have 100 agree the mentality that i was
able to receive from my parents and the
support when it was like okay this is
how you get insurance like my dad was
like hey here's my insurance broker um
that i use and i you know i was like 16
17 trying to figure out how to get
insurance so this is you know it's a
process and you learn and throughout
that whole experience i was able to hire
people i was able to hire my friends
fire all my friends hire people that got
paid a hundred thousand dollars a year
and thought that was like the biggest
expense ever you know rent a building
and having to pay for the rent of my
building for the whole year up front
because they were like there's no way
we're gonna rent this to you i was like
well what happens i pay for it all now
they're like okay we'll run it to you so
like getting through uh those stages and
be able to meet great people and connect
with great people in the community and
still like today to be able to say like
hey i know that person when i see them
in public like we still recognize each
other we still talk and chat which is
it's an amazing feeling and so it's not
you're not you're on this journey by
yourself you're on this journey with the
community and you're here i believe
we're all here to build you know the
future of the world and future finance
just briefly how was it hiring and
firing your friends
well i hired all my friends in 2017 with
mining stores it was like six guys in a
room doing phone calls you know it was
great we were making money but then like
things started getting bad and bitcoin
mining became unprofitable and bitcoin
started crashing and so my friends like
i had to let them all go eventually at
some point and they uh i've learned a
lot since then but i learned that like
you don't want to hire your friends uh
because they're friends they're not
working people they're not your business
partners it's better to go out in the in
the environment and find the right
people fit for the job versus just like
you know hey we're going to all jump on
this boat together and see where we go
yeah i totally agree with you
pleasure in business keep them separate
um
so the whole idea is to make mining
accessible for the average person
essentially is that correct that's
correct will world-class mining
facilities make mining accessible for
everyone so how do you do that
so that's the question i you know i've
been asking myself for for for years now
and like we've thought about nfts i
we've thought about um other routes
where um you could like buy a portion of
a bitcoin miner and have it run for you
but what we realized at the end of the
day was there is a really cool new
regulation out there called regulation
crowdfunding and so we launched a
product called bitvault which allows for
any influencer to start their own mining
company and we uh mining store provide
the services required to come keep those
miners running keep them operational and
the influencer basically makes content
about it similar to like a sponsor and
they end up owning about twenty percent
of the company so the influencer and
ourselves own twenty 20 and we sell 80
of it to the fans so the fans put in
their dollars you take an 80 20 split
similar to a hedge fund and you're able
to raise up to 5 million dollars legally
in the united states from on from
unregistered investors or unaccredited
investors so this means we can take 100
investments from anyone not only us
citizens but anyone in the world and you
don't even need to be a us citizen to
launch one you can be you know a uk
citizen and you can launch a reg cf
still so we're super excited to bring
bitcoin mining to the communities of all
these influencers and to allow anyone to
get into mining because we all know that
eight thousand dollars is way too
expensive for most of the population
yeah it really is um but then that sort
of brings me on to like my next question
which i often hear about um is the idea
that you know it's difficult to do it on
your own so you end up getting these
large mining pools um and then they
become centralized um so
are there any concerns there how do we
tackle that what would your response be
to that yeah so the mining pools um the
first pool ever came out was slush pool
and they existed because they the
network was getting too hard as you
mentioned so what we're focused on um or
what the mining industry is focused on
is getting steady payouts so mining
pools are necessary to provide steady
payouts to smaller miners anyone who has
less than 25 megawatts is probably doing
a pool mining and 25 megawatts is
hundreds of millions like 100 million
dollars worth of equipment today if it's
all new generation so it's very very
expensive you're not going to be able to
not join a pool if you're a consumer um
regarding the centralization of pools i
think that was definitely a problem more
in 2017 um today we have a lot of pools
a lot of great pool operators and a lot
of people um optimizing and innovating
in the pool space
in the future i don't think when i saw
you need mining pools i think that
mining pools are going to be like become
a layer two solution and will be built
into some like blockchains or other
software protocols um and they'll be
decentralized but we're getting there
yeah and i think that right now mining
is at this really awkward stage because
we've had well in the us you you know
you had the infrastructure bill where
you didn't have sort of that
clarification on you know the time
what's a broker
um and then you've also you've got like
this increased regulation and then
you've also got the fact that like
everything geopolitically is such a mess
whether it's you know china whether it's
you know
people moving from miners moving from
china to kazakhstan and the internet
getting shut down in kazakhstan because
of a protest and then miners setting up
in ukraine and then everything going on
so
we did see
you know the china shutdown of course
obviously affect the hash rate there was
a recovery but the price obviously still
took a hit so how are you navigating
that right now just the initial kind of
helping people set up shop and also just
knowing where to set up shop
so with bitcoin mining it's the only
real thing on the bitcoin blockchain
that physica that has a physical
existence in the real world like
nodes yes they do exist but they're very
easy to run you'll run them on a server
there's plenty of servers all over the
world and people don't have an issue
getting access to them when it comes to
the mining servers there are no
operations like them they're deploying
thousands of them it's a ton of power in
a concentrated area and you brought up
the geopolitical risk for ourselves we
focus on the united states we've looked
at we've looked at doing projects in
ukraine at nuclear power plants we've
looked at doing projects in in
uganda in nigeria in south in brazil in
canada we've always stuck to the us
because of the amount of abundant clean
energy we have here so the united states
is one of the biggest um developers of
clean energy and is pouring the most
amount of capital out of most countries
into clean energy so we have all of this
clean energy going in texas and in the
midwest and that energy actually can't
get to anyone uh because we're building
it away from population centers so that
provides a great opportunity for bitcoin
miners to come in and to arbitrage that
energy and to sell it to the bitcoin
network and buy it for pennies on the
dollar literally two cents three cents
per kilowatt hour so when it comes to
geopolitical risk we haven't
gone into those other countries due to
those issues because um financiers
insurance companies they all like the us
much better as a as a regime to you know
trust and we're seeing that the us is
respecting mining and it's also very
hard for the us to do a blanket ban of
mining like another country could
because of the different regulations
regarding power usage and the different
regulatory bodies and state local and
federal that regulate how the grid
operates and how what type of energy you
can use and how energy consumption works
but obviously i mean just from an
entrepreneurial standpoint i imagine
that eventually you would like to go
global is that right
so going global to me looks like going
global on the software level right so
yeah yeah
i i would love to build you know we're
working out how do we build large power
plants in these other countries but at
the end of the day like the majority of
mining machines um will be running at
one site and you can fit for example an
80 megawatt site we can fit 23 000
servers there that 20 those 23 000
servers at 100 a piece those could be
owned by let's say 2.3 million people
all across the world yes so that's the
goal is to scale with software and keep
the infrastructure
in the us in places where we know for a
fact that the representations we're
making online we're going to be able to
follow through over the five year period
in terms of
you know
these bands that we're seeing globally
just outside of you know your
infrastructure and everything that
you're building
how do you feel that that is going to
affect the network because we obviously
saw what happened with china um i know i
know obviously
the price recovered and so did the hash
rate but you know it did take some time
and then the same you know it's
concerning about the miners in russia
and kazakhstan and i think i also
actually know sorry ukraine um and i
think i also read again i don't quote me
on this because i can't remember exactly
what it was but i think i read that
they're shutting off
access to the internet outside of russia
so they're only going to be so they're
only going to have access to
russian internet but even a vpn won't be
enough to get around that so
you know how how does that affect the
network i mean i have no idea how the
russian miners are gonna pull that one
off and get and figure out how to do it
obviously uh there's the internet and
then there's uh other layers of
communication i don't know if the
bitcoin nodes can communicate without
the internet um on their own protocol so
i'm i know they use the internet as a
backbone but i'm unsure how that's gonna
affect uh the port you know i think the
port that all the nodes are on uh from
transmitting information and then
exactly exactly right affect the stratum
server or the servers connecting to the
mining pools um we'll see i think they
have five days that's what i heard
yesterday i was like damn five days to
make a whole new internet out here um
and i hope that you know i hope that the
miners who put up the money who invested
infrastructure right you know this is
this isn't just like building a website
where you can move it to another server
you're putting out exactly millions of
dollars of physical hardware you're
putting up millions of dollars of labor
electoral components so these are real
people's livelihoods that could be you
know in jeopardy uh because of this
these bitcoin mining slash internet bans
that are occurring in russia
yeah i mean does it concern you that you
know you've you've chosen the us because
you feel that it is
you know a safe place um you know it's
somewhat stable kind of um
does it concern you that mining could
become centralized and in the us you
know the same way we used to have those
kind of accusations about china
i think that it concerns me if there's
any one country that has more control of
50 of the hash rate and could dictate um
a you know some sort of protocol change
or did not necessarily protocol change
but dictate uh blocks reorgs or
something that the miners would have to
comply with to approve transactions and
only us-based blocks so i i like
decentralization and i think that we're
going to be continuing to build
decentralization layers on the pool
level and if that starts to happen then
as a minor you'll be able to connect to
a pool where they have no idea where
you're coming from um but at the end of
the day we all have uh legislators and
regulatory bodies we have to you know
listen to and uh not not avoid but like
follow the regulations they put out and
we want to have productive conversations
with them at the end of the day we're
here to
challenge how energy consumption and the
energy discussion is handled in the
united states uh mining store one of our
goals is to frame the energy
conversation of bitcoin energy is energy
well spent so you're when you're using
on bitcoin mining it's not like you're
going to going to waste when we talk we
don't talk about how much energy we're
using when we're traveling on a plane or
when we're driving to work or when we
watch netflix no we don't have that
conversation because it doesn't it
doesn't have a direct correlation
bitcoin mining has been selected as the
energy behemoth and like taking up all
the world's power but the reality is
it's very small like if if you look at
the concrete production and how much co2
that emits and how much energy concrete
production uses we're not saying we
shouldn't build roads anymore because
it's too bad for the environment
you know we're continuing to do that and
continue to expand our society
yeah i think there are two points there
it's
well it's the whole idea that like
bitcoin mining is a net positive
for the environment i think that's sort
of how satoshi put it um that it's a net
positive so i do just want to actually
break down the whole energy consumption
issue because i know there's still a lot
of people some people really watching
don't really understand it you know we
do see those major headlines um which
say you know
even even across europe actually at the
moment you know they're talking about
potentially banning and proof of work
because it's bad for the environment so
can you break down for us you know why
it's
not as bad as they say
and why is the net positive
so bitcoin mining is a net positive for
the energy usage because of i would say
three trends um the first one is the
the the amount of energy that is
consumed by consumers and the community
is
different for every hour of the day
so in the morning and in the evenings as
humans we all do two things and we we
wake up we make coffee and that actually
that like energy usage plus the heat
heat going on across all the us in the
world uh creates a energy usage like
resurgence so people need energy
but the energy production has to match
that energy consumption every single day
every single hour every single minute
unless the grid could fail and so what
bitcoin miners do is they help um
alleviate the peaks and valleys so the
peak would be when everyone's using
energy in the morning or the evening and
the valleys would be during the day when
we're not necessarily using as much
energy so bitcoin miners by adding more
consumption to the grid
allow a utility to say instead of having
to turn on let's say 10 megawatts of
coal plants to
give energy to the community we can
simply tell this bitcoin miner like we
do in iowa to turn off their mining
facility for that set two hours during
the day during the months where we
really need it and we can have them give
the energy back to the people so bitcoin
miners allow
more renewable energy production because
renewable energy production is not um
it's not consistent it's variable and so
that means you can't turn it on and off
like you can with coal and natural gas
which is how we meet those demands to
currently so by being able to build more
renewable energy we're able to um we're
able to effectively ensure that the
amount of energy consumed by consumers
that is renewable energy is a higher
percentage because now there's a
large consumer of that energy and then
when that renewable energy is available
and the grid needs it back the bitcoin
miner turns off because they're
financially incentivized to based on the
power rate so the power contract is set
up for this to happen now that right
there is why bitcoin miners and how they
play into the electric grid and and why
they're beneficial and not necessarily a
bad thing because they allow us to build
more renewable energy production that's
variable which then in return allows
everyone to win including the community
and do you find yourself having to sort
of
explain the difference between you know
how much
energy is wasted or used compared to
with bitcoin compared to the traditional
financial system i mean do you know the
stats off the top of your head i know
that i don't
okay i i know i know that i know that
the traditional system and even gold the
whole entire production of gold is just
so much more um than bitcoin um well i
wanna that's i think i still think
you're comparing right so when you're
when you start fighting that argument
you start playing like we're gonna
compare us to real estate to gold what
we're really saying is energy usage is
bad you're still playing into their
argument that energy use is bad but
they're we're better than that yeah so
the goal is not to compare energy usage
at all to anyone the goal is to say
energy usage is actually a net positive
for society and using energy can
can allow us to become more productive
can bring more people out of poverty and
can provide more jobs and economic
freedom and increase gdp so they've seen
and there's some great articles by nick
carter on this that
as a country uses more energy they have
a lower death rate they have a lower uh
a birth rate when it comes to deaths
during you know childbirth they have a
better um lifestyle they have a longer
age of living so that's one thing then
when in addition there's something
called the energy value that's energy
with an m and energy value is the unit
of calculation of how much energy went
into an asset to create it so that one
of the highest energy value assets is
steel
and steel is very valuable to society
and that's why it's valuable is because
you put a lot of energy into it and now
people are building a building with it
because it's so strong so the same thing
goes with bitcoin bitcoin will has a
high energy value because we're putting
tons of energy into the asset itself
which then in return makes it more
valuable to society so i see bitcoin
mining as that positive feedback loop
that helps ensure that every four years
the padding happens bitcoins become
harder to get they require double the
amount of energy to acquire which then
pushes the price up and provides more
more jobs more megawatts to be deployed
and more mining machines working in the
mines so i think that bitcoin's energy
usage we shouldn't compare to other
industries instead we should say as a
society we should be proud of the energy
we use we should be proud of how much
energy we're using and we want to use it
in an environmentally friendly way
yeah i understand i think that the
reason people tend to do that though is
just because
there's like this double standard and
there's this kind of concern that
there's an ulterior motive going on i
mean
there seems to be such a lack of nuance
um especially in the states with the
politicians when it comes to talking
about bitcoin mining so
i wonder if you
have any opinion on you know why there's
a lack of nuance do you think it's just
because they don't understand or do you
think you know it's because
having that nuance and you know
having a bitcoin for any environment
poses a threat to the us dollar and then
they don't want that yeah i think
bitcoin you know is the first thing to
say hey we can do money without you as a
state uh that's why you know in 2013 i
became interested in in it when i was in
high school it's for that one reason i
didn't need to ask anyone permission i
could get on get on the bitcoin network
i could buy bitcoin and i could uh you
know transact without having to be uh 15
years old i could you know do as a young
person so for me when it comes to
bitcoin mining and how the energy debate
is being framed i think it's important
that um we understand that energy
creation and manufacturing which is what
bitcoin mining is where manufacturing
new bitcoin is viewed as a net positive
across the world and across the united
states they communities want
manufacturing jobs they love it they
want they want jobs they want energy
usage they want to build their community
when you tell them we're manufacturing
bitcoin they're like wait what there's
no product there but that doesn't mean
they don't want it when you when you
talk about data centers coming in and
building a data center everyone says yes
we want our data center yes we want it
it doesn't matter that it's using energy
it doesn't matter they have not that
many jobs we need the data centers and
so with bitcoin mining i think the
politicians can't say yes it's a good
thing because this is one of their key
this will be one of their key uh i guess
points that why we should regulate
bitcoin and why bitcoin's bad is because
it uses energy and that's why i'm saying
that debate is we need to reframe it of
like energy usage isn't inherently bad
bitcoin mining uses energy but it also
helps produce more renewable energy and
allow the grid to be more
reliable more sustainable and more
dynamic without that you don't have a
grid that works grids have to meet
consumption and production 24 7 and you
need a lot of both in order to match it
up with renewable energy that's um you
know variable can you delve into the
whole energy arbitrage thing because i
think that is the most interesting part
because this is the first because this
is the first time we're seeing energy
decentralized right yeah effectively
bitcoin mining is a the global buyer of
energy so anywhere in the world you can
export these electrons through the
bitcoin mining computers which turn the
electrons into heat that's the only
output there's no radioactive material
nothing comes out of it that's bad
there's only heat the heat gets
exhausted and the what happens when
you're creating that heat is the
computers are doing a math problem that
math problem in return gets rewarded
bitcoins uh from the pool for
contributing their work to the pool or
to the bitcoin network and that process
right there is effectively taking
electricity that's stranded that's in
the midwest that's has nowhere to go
we're looking at uh some wind farms and
a few of them generate energy and 75
percent of the time they're putting
energy in the ground because they can't
actually get it on the transmission line
the transmission line's already full no
one needs it but that project that i'm
talking about has been there for 12 13
years and so it's already paid off the
investor's already done now it's like
we're gonna you know dismantle it or we
don't need it anymore and so the fact is
is that there's plenty of energy the
problem is energy is not in the right
spot
because it's hard to transmit energy we
have less transmission lines here in the
united states because it's if we
incentivize energy production with like
green energy credits and wrecks and um
but we don't incentivize transmission of
energy or consumption of energy you know
you don't get paid to consume energy
what happens if you did well as a
bitcoin miner you do get paid to use
energy and you're selling that energy to
the bitcoin network and that's the one
paying you so bitcoin provides this um
almost like
what i would call like basic um wealth
or universal basic income to anyone who
wants to plug a computer in and wants to
arbitrage energy and so with mining
store we're working on getting the
lowest cost energy so that the people on
our platform can arbitrage the energy at
two or three cents to the to the bitcoin
network and make you know and sell for
25 cents 30 cents 40 cents whatever the
bitcoin price is and get that arbitrage
all day long and never have to actually
go to the facility and work and plug in
the machines and deal with the noise we
don't we don't want that we just want
them to say okay get on a 100 level be
able to quickly get an allocation to the
space and do it through software because
that's the future of bitcoin mining as
we see it for consumers
yeah i really want to do this i have to
get involved um when i think about a
year ago elon musk was it a year ago no
nearly it was about may last year or
maybe even april to be honest elon musk
made that whole u-turn with tesla
because of his environmental concerns
how um how genuine do you think his
environmental concerns were
i think elon's a very smart guy um as
you saw with his cree even he's like we
need to ramp up natural gas and oil
production in the u.s i can't believe
i'm saying this but um
the thing is is elon has people who he
needs to
you know keep his friends and when
you're getting hundreds of millions and
billions of dollars of tax credits and
um
and you know renewable energy advocates
and battery storage credits and all the
the tax advantages he's getting
the the face of
only clean energy that elon puts on
you know he has to maintain it and with
bitcoin mining
i think he got a knock on the door from
someone and said hey you can't you can't
be saying this like you guys bought
bitcoin that was already enough now
you're coming out and saying bitcoin is
good that doesn't fit our agenda that's
my personal opinion and i think he knows
the fact that as a society we need to
use more energy and he's heard of those
theories and that he understands that he
wants to make it more clean energy and
bitcoin mining is one way to increase
adoption of clean energy and grid
reliability
yeah it's interesting i tend to think
that he
i think it was just a mistake
like
i cuz i i feel like okay i could be
totally wrong but i feel i feel he's a
bit i do think he's kind of honest
um you know i don't think he's one of
those shady characters i mean you never
really know do you um but
i tend to think he's more of an honest
one um and i feel it was just a mistake
he didn't really understand it it's why
it took him so long to get involved
um you know i i think it was just a
mistake i'm not really sure um
but it is interesting and you know where
do you where do you then see this going
over the next 10 years um you know i
feel like we're in the middle of this
battle right now um you know climate
change their narrative around climate
change is certainly heating up um
you know to what extent do you think
bitcoin's going to take the brunt of it
to what extent do i think bitcoin is
going to take the brunt of what
again of this climate change narrative
that's heating up
i think i mean bitcoin will be in front
and center in the climate change debate
as we just continue to move forward and
as society progresses because it uses so
much energy and i think bitcoin
what we're seeing now is it's actually
becoming a feature to the energy
companies so the energy companies who
own the energy assets are looking to
build bitcoin mines at their facilities
when they can't sell their power to the
grid and so now the end of the the big
players are coming in per se like right
now it's been the small guys and it's
been if you didn't have really cheap
energy it was hard to compete but now
that bitcoin is where it's at and the
price point it's been stable the market
is changing the market has a problem
where there's too much production and
not enough consumption i think the
market will dictate um
the bitcoin mining like deployments in
the us regarding the policy discussion
and the news cycle i i we've seen
bitcoin mining you know be pronounced
dead hundreds of times i think we're
going to see bitcoin mining energy usage
be continued to be debated and there has
to be more research and more community
effort to bring awareness to energy
usage being an inherently good thing and
not bad yeah i think el salvador is
obviously this kind of
experiment slash shining light slash
something something that's going on
right now um you know it isn't it is an
experiment and it is like some shining
light
when it comes to you know innovation um
so the volcanoes are really interesting
have you had a chance to check them out
yet
i i have never been to the volcanoes but
i have had conversations with parties
who are mining crypto in el salvador uh
we consult with a few groups down there
um and we you know we are reviewing
geothermal as an energy source and how
in you know how to drill geothermal
wells to generate clean energy as i see
it's one of the best ways to generate uh
renewable energy that's 24 7. and so i
think its applications for bitcoin
mining are tremendous
do you think like the us is ever going
to do something similar you know the way
they've built what they've built you
know with the government backing
um you know it's just so crazy well the
us i think takes the position of let's
let the private companies generate the
energy and uh sell them to the grid and
in in the energy companies their goal is
not to
uh to get the rate the consumer pays to
be lower the goal of energy companies to
get more assets on their balance sheet
to pay bigger debts and interest so that
their consumer the person who's buying
the power has to pay uh for those fees
so that they can get more assets on the
utilities balance sheet so at the end of
the day we are making geothermal energy
in the united states we are there's
plants that do it in california um and i
don't i see that we need more clean
energy throughout the world and we need
more nuclear we need more
geothermal and i realize even things
like hydro you consider that renewable
energy but that has um a ton of this
this the water that's stable and it's
like stale actually causes like co2
emissions and has uh you know biogas and
uh different types of issues with it so
um i think the geothermal and nuclear
path are a great way for us to deploy a
lot of energy but it's not what we're
looking at we're looking at solar and
wind because it's um being subsidized by
the government where geothermal is not
i'm with you um you're also the founder
of rm capital ventures am i even
pronouncing that correctly that's
correct
so tell tell me about that where does
that fit into everything yeah so that's
the parent company that we have that
owns uh every different llc we have so
we're in the mining space we're also in
the helium space we're launching a
helium um a minor which is the people's
internet um we are in um
we're in the consulting space we have
different product lines we're in the
software space so we separate each one
of our companies out underneath it and
build brands for like the mining store
and for bit vault based on what the
consumer or who the audience is and orem
capital ventures is the parent company
which we receive investment into and
which our employees gain shares from or
you know get get option contracts and
kind of invest into and get ownership in
it
so what's the overall goal for you
because you obviously you know you
started this in 2017 which actually
somebody tweeted uh today saying 2017 is
five years ago which is actually insane
that's five years ago so it's time time
is getting on so what's you know the
next big thing are you just going to be
dedicating your career and your life to
mining or are you looking at anything
else are you interested in proof of
stake you know so i like steak but not
proof of steak um i'm dedicated
i'm dedicating my you know my resources
and time and talent to making bitcoin
mining more accessible to everyone so
anyone can get into this space making
bitcoin mining um
cheaper for the energy so working on
figuring out what's the best energy mix
how do i get the lowest cost energy and
i love the energy space i love building
massive buildings i love construction
and i love software because i was a
computer science major in school and i'm
realizing that to make an impact on the
world you need to you know have a
radical idea and for me that radical
idea is energy usage is a good thing and
let's incentivize energy usage flip the
argument on its head and let's show off
you know how much energy layla and her
bitcoin miners and her whole community
is using and let's have her compete with
you know natalie or with josh terry or
with mr beast who had a bitcoin mine so
there's all these influencers who have
mined bitcoin in the past they might not
have told you about it or they're
currently mining crypto and we want to
make it a public thing that
we share like a social media for
influencers to focus on finances and
raising money through the regulated
crowdfunding framework i think that
framework is going to change how we sell
our time so you know most people sell
their time for money i think in the
future we should sell our time for
equity and i think everyone should have
a regulated crowdfund that they own and
they can create content about an
industry and get their fans to put money
into it to be owners with them and they
get to build really cool things uh with
their fans so that's what i'm excited
for when i'm eager to build and you know
the journey is just starting um in the
software space for us
and it's also
interesting because you know you have to
have a huge you know desire for
decentralization and love for
decentralization in order to sort of you
know
devote a career and to build everything
that you're building so i'd like to
understand where that interest comes
from you know what what is it about
decentralization what is it about
bitcoin for you
um you know that has allowed you to
dedicate so much time energy and you
know all these resources to it
so what i would say for me is that
underlying um belief that you know money
is by the people for the people and
money should work for you and not
against you when i make the decision to
hold us dollars in my bank account or to
transact in u.s dollars i'm effectively
saying that the you know i'm using money
that is depreciating in value when i'm
using bitcoin i'm using money that is
the the best store of value in the world
that you know was recreated with tons of
energy and that is inherently valuable
that's the belief that keeps me going
all day long
the belief that no one should be able to
tell you based on your race your age
your religion
if you can or can't do a transaction i
think that we all should have that
should be a god-given right and that's
what i'm looking to build on top of
which is not only should we receive be
able to use these networks we show these
networks work for us and bitcoin mining
put out 25 billion dollars last year in
mining revenue and we want to get that
into the people's hands we want to get
as many consumers mining bitcoin at an
at a hundred dollar price point and
becoming um you know opening up that
gate of wealth creating uh freedom for
those individuals showing them that you
can create money through the bitcoin
mining process and you can come out at
the end of the day with more bitcoin
than you had uh you know getting into
the investment or mining without with
you know without starting mining that's
that's the end goal the end goal is to
give people that flexibility freedom
that i got to experience and i get to
experience in my life because i was able
to be on this technol technological
trend you know earlier than most
the thing is you got into in
2016-17 so you must have been
around 18 or 19. so i got into crypto
2013 but then mining 2016.
okay so
well
okay wow that's even younger how old are
you in 2013. i think we're a similar age
i was like 14. i'm 24 now oh okay you
you're you weren't 14 in 2013.
i was older 15 14 right 15. i'm 24 now
15 and 20
yeah
20 22. oh my god okay
right so i was 15 years old over here
and that's okay 15 15. yeah
yeah loving crypto
yeah but so but the thing is it must
have been
it must have been the tech like that's
why you got into it right yeah i mean i
was so i in high school i was taking
like macro and microeconomic classes and
i like loved that and i was like
byzantine generals theory like why does
bitcoin work and i was the kid i went to
a small high school 50 people per class
and i was the kid who just told everyone
about bitcoin got my teachers into it
and now it's the running joke like when
i go back to speak at schools they're
like oh my god like we should have
bought bitcoin and then same thing in
college like that's just who i've been
because i'm obsessed with the technology
and also i'm weird enough where i'll
state my facts and opinions and be like
i don't have to be the normal one i
don't have to believe what everyone else
is believing and i'll be the guy that's
like hey you should buy bitcoin at 70 a
coin to my family and now i'm the same
guy here pitching the same stuff it's
because i truly believe with my heart
that bitcoin is the best thing for the
world when it comes to money and it's
the best money for the world it's
freedom and so that's why i'm working on
building products that kind of let
people get out of that nine-to-five job
let them get out of that confused state
where they're barely making it by my
goal is to build wealth for society and
i want to do build wealth through clean
energy and bitcoin mining which are both
massive industrial processes
infrastructure builds wealth and there's
plenty of good research on
showing that infrastructure builds
society and builds gdp and i think
bitcoin mining clean energy has the
ability to do that for communities
across the globe
but when did you my question is like
when did you have that realization
because you you were the guy that was in
it for the tech right and now you end up
with the freedom and i do
i think there's a difference there
for me i think i started with the
freedom right so the reason why no you
started with the tech you were like the
nerdy kid you were just saying that was
telling your teachers to buy it for 70
cents yeah well so i'm telling them to
buy for 70 but why am i interested in it
i'm interested in it because no one can
tell me what i can't find can he can't
do which is but how do you have that
realization at 15
you read wikipedia and you realize that
like i mean for me like i'm trying to
think back then
i
there was no issues back when we were 15
we're like a similar age there were no
issues when we were 15. i remember when
i was 15 thinking the world was so easy
people told you you couldn't do
something and i didn't like that i was
defying that like as a since a young kid
i've always defined defied like societal
standards of like what's okay with
school and like what do you have an
example like what for example like the
first day of high school the first
second day of high school or second year
of high school i they had a rule book i
went to an early college so we could
leave the college campus and they if we
didn't have class and so i read both the
rule books and i was like here's the
rules you guys just put it out we just
all signed it here's the other rules
therefore i don't have a class i'm not
going to be counted absent so i'm going
to leave it's like that was my mentality
as a sophomore in high school and like
in middle school i was you know always
trying to figure out how to how to build
this next thing like starting robotics
camp i'm always trying to to basically
innovate and build value for people
because at a young age i had this this
this like there's not discernment but
this vision of like hey you need to uh
pay for your own [ __ ] like you need to
you need to create value in the world
for my dad and so
as a 15 year old i'm trying to solve my
financial problems and then i've
realized like okay how do you do that
effectively well i'm not going to sell
my time i'm going to build businesses
and so that believe in that structure
being a business owner i've never had
guard rails right i dropped out of
school so like we had the guardrails i
was like i don't want to do this anymore
i'm done same thing with business like
you have the guardrails but in the
business the gargoyles are really really
broad and you can play in that space so
i've always been someone to play in that
arena because i believe that
you know bitcoin is a life-changing
technology because it is a free it's
freedom freedom for the world freedom
for everyone and it's the the protocol
you know the trust protocol as we would
call it or as mark usko would say
selling um not selling time for dollars
is um it sounds really obvious but i
definitely think it's like an advanced
sort of mentality that not the average
person um is sort of aware of so did
your dad teach you that or is that
something you've read or you came across
or realized on your own it's something
that i i think i believe i developed it
like i read the four hour work week over
time i was always trying to create value
by that being an arbitrage like by
selling the strawberries or by robotics
camp the way i positioned that in my
brain was like okay if i can get a hot
10 kids at 15 an hour or ten dollars an
hour that's 150 or 50 you know 15 kids
at 15 an hour like that's going to be um
more effective than me working at 12
hour dollars an hour at a job so like
that's when i started comparing like
okay i can get 10x my revenue here and
then eventually you're like okay i won't
sell my time for money at all i'm only
interested in building equity and that's
what i want to help the world get to is
that belief that they want to be an
owner in their company they want to sell
equity and selling your time for dollars
is secure it gives you that sense of
security
but it doesn't give you that it's fake
it's fake right it's not it's not real
so why do you
do what you do today i'm curious now to
hear me yourself oh god what's the
question
so why are you in crypto and what are
your beliefs behind it oh well i'm a
die-hard freedom maximalist don't tell
me what to do i'm competent on my own i
don't need the daddy government to tell
me what to do um look like i think i
think that um humans can truly prosper
um once they're left to prosper on their
own right like it's kind of like a we're
like plants
um and you know if you keep if you keep
like over over nurturing the plant and
you keep doing too much to it i think it
will die if you just give it you know
the correct environment um i think it
can flourish and be very beautiful um
and i really believe in like personal
responsibility and that's what i love
about bitcoin um because
so i i've kind of like taken bitcoin to
the extreme so like you know the whole
idea of like don't um don't trust verify
i now like
double check everything in my life you
know everything you know have have a
backup plan be you know really verify
don't trust that that's gonna work out
so i just i just sort of feel we should
um you know empower people to take
personal responsibility i think that um
you know governments are too uh act like
a nanny state too much and i think that
that um i think that that disempowers
people um so and was that yeah created
by society or your parents like how did
you come up with that belief as well
that's a great question um i know what
seemed like me
i'm sorry i'm very sorry
i'm really sorry um i think that well
firstly my i have an older brother he's
two years older than me and he
definitely sort of red peeled me if you
like um
but just overall i think that um
you know i sort of just seen that things
aren't going to be handed to you
um and you have to just sort of
you can get anything you want as long as
as long as you create it um and you know
as well like if you rely on the
government you're only going to get x
far
but if you rely on yourself you'll get
much further because you have all the
control like you have all the control
over everything so you really can pull
as many strings as you like right you
can call the shots and you can create as
much as you want if you have to rely on
a government or something like that then
you're you're kind of you're stuck in a
box and then also i think like
governments are corrupt and so on and so
on but anyway this like i don't know
talk all about me okay that this so this
is theory called i watched a documentary
called hyper normalization and the fact
the belief is is like we are currently
know the system is broken like society
is realizing today especially with the
war that the system is breaking is
broken and we're all just acting like
everything's okay
and we all are aware that everyone else
has no idea what they're doing everyone
else is acting and there's this thing
called inflation that just keeps on uh
digging away at everything we're trying
to buy and making it more expensive
so the people are going to continue to
wake up because their standard of living
is getting crushed right now and they're
going to be asking for where is a
monetary supply that i can put my
capital into that is different than this
fake money that we're all believing
exists and the prices keep going up
every day with the internet with the how
fast tick tock and instagram can push uh
media and news i see an advent where now
we have an opportunity to opt out and
it's plan b it's bitcoin
yeah it's really exciting and i think
that um
right now we're in this really weird
kind of
push and pull phase um
because like you know there's so much to
bitcoin and it's not just you know
opting out like there is this kind of
entrepreneurial side of it just because
it does require you to take personal
responsibility um you know over over
your keys over your finances it's just a
mentality
but the the other side of the coin
is that we also live in a world where
some people just i mean i don't know if
this is true but i'm just gonna sort of
say it some people just sort of aren't
built that way um you know some people
prefer security some people prefer uh we
all prefer security
um
okay yes but we but we but what we what
we perceive as secure is different right
like you and i would think that nine to
five is really dangerous yeah i would
agree with that
but we all have these natural rights
that we're looking to
uh ensure and you know for me that's
that's that's cash flow for for anyone
that's cash flow that's ensuring that
they have uh something set away for the
future and that they know they're not
gonna have to work their their whole
life um the thing the thing about
bitcoin is that you know with the
internet anyone can access these beliefs
now and we can express these beliefs
like we are today and before that the
information just didn't get out as fast
and now with bitcoin you can own part of
the protocol and like i said no one has
to ask for permission so it's exploding
across the world and
i i am excited to be building alongside
people like yourself who are really
passionate as well in sharing the
message because
it's important it's important that it's
out there because there's plenty of
people saying dick reminding energy
usage is bad and someone has to tell
them it's not and it's here for the
betterment of society
absolutely just one last question then
um
how religious would you say bitcoin is
and the reason i ask this
is because um
so i don't believe i don't think it's
like religious in terms of like you know
a cult or anything like that you know
but i think it's kind of like religious
in terms of like you dedicate your life
to an idea an idea that people should
take personal responsibility people
should be free people should be
sovereign and people should be
independent um from um you know
government systems
and then you sort of build your life
around this you know whether it's you
know your social life probably is your
social life you know dating life work
life
you know everything about your life is
really surrounded by this philosophy and
this ideology um so yeah how sort of
religious would you say it is
so i think
bitcoin is uh religious in the sense
that it it maintains this pretense of a
way that society can function so it
creates this delusion which at the end
of the day becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy of
um
a new way of doing business a new way of
control a new belief that this is how it
should be
so we're we're basically the dollar and
the euro and these things that we
believe in are created because of a mass
hallucination between millions of
individuals that say yes this thing
exists
but the dollar
it doesn't exist it exists because it
affects our world and it has momentum
and it means something to everyone in
the world
we decide to trade our time for that
dollar but if you take away
the dollars being worth anything and
that they're just pieces of paper we are
no longer going to trade our time for
that so i believe that bitcoin is the
same way where it is a mass
hallucination and the goal is to get as
many people
believers into the hallucination because
it's better for them it's better for
society if we run on bitcoin than if we
run on dollars
it's like how long do you think until
we're a society that runs on bitcoin
i think we need to clarify that farther
i would say if you can clarify as a
society that runs on bitcoin being 50 of
the transactions are happening in
bitcoin
uh like 100 years i think it's gonna
take a long time to get there yeah
but that's where we're here and we're
building for the future that you know
our kids will experience in the world
i think um
i tend to agree but i think it'd be much
faster i mean the reason i think we're
much faster is because life is crazy
right now like we i didn't yeah i didn't
interview with mark moss last week and
he was talking about like peak
centralization coming at like 2025 um
and i think once that happens
that's when we go on to the bitcoin
standard here's why i disagree with you
okay the amount of bonds traded in u.s
dollars is insane trillions of dollars
it makes anything on the bitcoin network
look small so this whole financial
system of financialization of assets in
oil and gas and real estate
uh is is massively big and that's what
made me believe that money doesn't exist
that money is a complete hallucination
that even trading your time for a
thousand dollars an hour is still not
worth it and you should be building
equity in a business that you own
because the amount of dollars created in
the financials financial markets through
these ways of seasoning debt and doing
these interesting intricate financial
transactions make a day-to-day consumer
purchase even a real estate purchase
looks so small look insignificant buying
a half a million dollar home because of
the scale and size of these papers that
are being pushed
okay jp um where can people follow you
get involved with your work you know the
mining store how can people get involved
sure so you can reach out to us at sales
monitor.com if you're interested in uh
getting mining you can check out the
miningstore.com website you can message
me or check follow me on twitter at jp
barrick on instagram at john paul
barrick that's b-a-r-i-c on tick tock as
jp barrick and if you're looking to work
with a great team and help build the
vision you can email us at hiring at
miningstore.com and we're always looking
for a great people to work with
sounds amazing well jp i want to thank
you so much it's been so interesting
hearing your perspective on bitcoin life
entrepreneurship um it's the perfect
match for my show so it's really great
having you on thank you so much thanks
again i appreciate it yeah absolutely
and guys please don't forget to hit the
subscribe button hit the like button so
you never miss um one of my brilliant
guests and we will see you all next week
[Applause]
[Music]